well the White House says President
Trump has been briefed on the shooting
Margaret Brennan is at the White House
Margaret good morning it looks like the
president has issued his first tweet
related to the shooting that's right the
president has been awake for some time
the lights have been on here in the
residence and he just moments ago posted
his first response to this horrific mass
shooting saying he sends his warmest
condolences and sympathies to the
victims and families of the terrible Las
Vegas shooting god bless you
we also moments ago got a statement from
the White House confirming that it was
chief of staff John Kelly who first
briefed the President on what was
unfolding in Las Vegas the chief of
staff formerly ran homeland security has
a military background and is often the
first point of contact for the president
though in these circumstances you would
have expected Tom Bossert the
president's Homeland Security Advisor
and counterterrorism adviser to have
done so he of course is leading that
hurricane response effort and it was
John Kelly this morning who first told
the president the White House telling us
they are viewing this as just a horrific
tragedy they are monitoring it closely
and they have offered a full assistance
to state and local authorities so at
this point not saying that this is being
taken over as at some sort of federal
investigation but reasserting that they
are offering full support to the local
people on the ground in Las Vegas and
while we are just now getting this
response we do know throughout the
morning the president has been
monitoring media his social media
director has been retweeting and sending
out information from the local police
there about what looks to be one of the
deadliest mass shootings well at this
point it is the deadliest mass shooting
in US history Margaret Brennan at the
White House thank you